suivez-moi le monde est constitué
d'histoire et tous ces histoires sont
rassemblés mais la plus extraordinaire
d'entre elles débutent le jour des morts
bonjour ou les esprits passe d'un monde
alors que c'est bien c'est pas amoureuse
d'une fille je vous ai dit que j'avais
aussi appris les scream vous vous
conduisez tous les deux comme des
crétins moi aussi
elle a pas l'air très comme ben dis donc
mais si on se faisait un petit pari je
parie que maria épousera jouette le pari
est lancé
manolo magnifique je ne serai pas le
héros de la ville mariale et je te jure
du fond du coeur que jamais je ne
cesserai des mais je vais être le pari
serait que le moi ça au plus vite mon
vieil ami
mais où suis-je
bienvenue au pays des hommes chez dit
accroche pas bien
si tu réussisses épreuve alors tu pourra
revoir marque
madame je vous en prie aidez moi à
retrouver l'amour de ma vie
oui
oh
maria tu croyais que ce serait si facile
que ça